argument number one a woman has the
right to choose answer no nobody has a
universal right to choose we all agree
that some choices must be prohibited the
question is not if women should be able
to choose generally but if they should
be able to choose to intentionally
destroy innocent human life if you say
they do then you have to defend that
choice on its merits you can't defend
the choice based simply on the fact that
it is one pro-lifers want to control
women's bodies answer no the body in
dispute is not the mothers the question
again is whether the body of the human
in her womb can be intentionally
destroyed the child's body is the one at
issue here and we as pro-lifers are the
ones trying to defend it three
pro-lifers are only pro-birth they don't
care about babies after they're born
answer you have no data or evidence to
support that stupid claim besides our
position is that babies in the womb have
moral worth equal to babies outside of
course we believe babies outside have
worth that's the whole basis of our
argument our assertion is that babies in
the womb have worth and that's based on
our contention that babies and all
people outside have worth our argument
hinges on the comparison between humans
inside and outside the womb